so for me the guiding principle is that
I'll start with monetary policy that
when we take decisions on monetary
policy of course we always depend
whatever the outside the conditions in
the World At Large are we always take
Financial conditions into account and
setting monetary policy because
obviously it's one of the one of the
influences of those decisions
and that's natural it depends no matter
where it's a good time or a less good
time
what we shouldn't be doing is saying
we've got such a problem with financial
stability that we have to and sense aim
off
a decision on monetary policy which is
taken with obviously with our inflation
Target and primary view because of
conditions and financial stability I
think to go that step further one thing
to say we always take Financial
conditions into account but it's another
step to say
and and in those situations of stress
let's say we have to aim off monetary
policy because we're concerned about the
stability of the financial system
now two things are fish on that we we
clearly haven't we have not had to do
that in this situation and it's never
been an issue
and that's important for me the second
thing I would say is that there's an
intermediary step as well which is that
we have tools of of of macro potential
policy which we can use to address
yeah present Financial stability
concerns credit concerns so an obvious
one is that if we felt it was
appropriate we would react lower the
counter cyclical Capital buffer as a
first step so that's again you know a
set of particular tools that we've
developed for financial stability which
are there to address those issues rather
than having to say let's go straight to
interest rates and do something
different with interest rates and I
think that's very important
so very clear
distinction between
monetary policy aims and financial
stability aims and we have different set
of tools and we have different
institutions set up in order to deal
with these objectives but that's correct
but I think we always have to be very
focused on how do the pieces fit
together so how do we sort of bring
these various pieces of policy making
into alignment so that they work
together
let me move to another topic what are
the early lessons from the bank of
England's quantitative
tightening implementation and how do you
see the interaction between the policy
rate hikes and the Bois balance sheet
reduction what is your envisioned
endpoint for the BYU balance sheet and
how do you see this in comparison with
the fed and easy B
well start with two two two big points
on this I think first of all
um we've been very clear that when we do
not regard quantitative tightening as
our active monetary policy tool
what I mean by that and it sort of comes
back to what I was saying a few minutes
ago is it's operating in the background
we've been very clear that we will use
it continuously but since we think that
the effects of quantitative easing were
state contingent
if we got into stressed market
conditions it is an option for us to
suspend quantitative tightening and by
the way of course last October we
actually delayed the start of it because
we thought we were in those sorts of
conditions so we wanted to operate in
the background not as the primary tool
and then as I was saying a few moments
ago
obviously any impact it has on credit
conditions on financial conditions will
come through naturally through financial
conditions through market prices and so
on and we'll take it into account
through that channel as we always would
that's that's the first thing
the second thing I think is a really
interesting question is of course as you
rightly said where's it all going to in
that sense now
I I think there's an important point to
make here
monetary policy in respect to
quantitative easing
operated
through both through the interest rate
Channel and the asset Channel but
monetary policy also operates of course
on the liability side of the central
bank balance sheet because we're
effectively transmitted at the start of
the transmission mechanism through the
rate we pay on reserve reserves held in
reserve Accounts at the bank of England
but those Reserve accounts are also
critical for financial stability
because the liquidity buffers that that
Banks now hold they are an important
element of the of the stock of high
quality liquidity so if you take the
major UK banks at the moment
about one and a half trillion pounds of
liquidity coverage ratio high quality
assets of which currently somewhere I
think between 800 and 900 billion is
reserves and cash
now
two things I'll say about that one one
thing
the reserve levels from a financial
stability point of view were far too low
prior to the financial crisis
I mean we had Reserve levels that were
down in the sort of I think if I
remember right about 30 billion or
something at one point and of course
what that meant was that the financial
crisis was I think made more difficult
because the banks did not have adequate
liquidity buffers probably an important
part of which is reserve accounts
now I say I give that a bit of History
because I think that when we consider
today what the steady state level of
Reserve System is much higher than it
was pre-crisis so we're not going back
to the pre-crisis position another way
of saying that is
part of the QE that we have done
actually we would have had to expand the
central bank balance sheet anyway
because of this need to increase
reserves for financial stability reasons
now
you can rightly say to me so where's the
target then and the answer is well we
don't know actually where we're going to
where it's going to settle at because
that depends upon what you might call
the equilibrium level of Reserves
um all I would say is I think it's going
to be substantially higher than it was
pre-crisis and it's going to be clearly
lower than it is today but where it is
and of course it can vary over time as
well it's not a fixed number
now the the the final element of the
pieces and what would be the composition
of your assets on the central bank
balance sheets in that steady state
world because it doesn't have to be the
same as it is today I would imagine that
we would have a a larger stock of repo
assets that we would turn over at higher
frequency and then probably some stock
of steady state you know steady state
assets that we would also have so yeah
we are
we're heading in that direction
but a key point to make makers that the
quantitative tightening process
is going to bring the Central Bank the
bank of England's balance sheet down
um it will bring it down to whatever
that equilibrium level is it may or we
may all take it on beyond that to say to
give the Headroom for Stocker repo
assets but it's not going down to where
it was my view it's not going down to
where it was pre-crisis and we're
obviously going to have to watch very
carefully for when we hit that
resistance point and that's by the way
when why when we started quantitative
tightening we also reintroduced a
standing repo facility it's not being
used at the moment but at any moment on
any day if we hit that resistance Point
we'd be ready to sort of wheel it out
and ensure that the short-term Market
rates was obviously consistent with the
with the monetary policy rate so rolling
off in in the background not the primary
policy tool uh to some extent learning
by doing because that's something we
haven't really done done before and we
don't know what the impact is on the
functioning of the financial market and
monetary transmission
well we also we well on that point I
mean we watch it very carefully because
we do not want it to have
a detrimental effect on functioning
markets and a functioning of of monetary
transmission now you know our markets
team watch this every day and they you
know report to me every day pretty much
on where we are what we're not seeing
we're not seeing a movement in any of
the indicators we look at for the
functioning of markets so liquidity of
markets bid our spreads all these things
we're not seeing anything that sort of
stands out in that respect
good uh turning to financial stability
we have seen some Bank resolutions in
the past few weeks what does this tell
us about the resilience of the banking
sector more broadly what are your
initial thoughts on how the post 2008
reforms including resolution Frameworks
have performed do you have any
Reflections on the implications and
lessons learned from these events for
the UK or more broadly
well
let me say first of all I think what
we've seen in the last few weeks as you
say is is pockets of issues coming up in
parts of the banking sector I believe
and I've said a number of times said
again this morning
I do not see the evidence that we've got
uh on our hands what I would call the
sort of the the makings of a you know
2007-8 financial crisis I really don't
see that actually I think the system is
in a much more robust condition and we
have got a that's the first point of
Defense but the second point of defense
is that we've got a lot more Tools in
our Armory uh to deal with these things
than we had in 2007 and eight and eight
when we were sort of somewhat making it
up as we um we hit the crises and so it
was so we're in a very different place
and I don't see you know I really don't
see this as the sort of the beginnings
of a systemic financial crisis in that
sense but you're right of course that
there are learning uh you know there are
learning points uh lessons learned from
all of these issues that we run into
um
and we will have to you know both
domestically and globally and
particularly globally in the financial
stability board
you know spend spend a lot of time
thinking these things through and I
think if I had to pick some out so far
of things that I've observed I mean I'll
pick three things out
um one is this what I call speed of run
which we saw particularly I think with
with Silicon Valley Bank
um and there's two parts to that in a
way one is the sort of the you know the
changes in communication technology
second one is
um is is obviously the ease of access to
the bank accounts to to move them and
move them and withdraw them but you can
take it a bit you can take it beyond
that concentrated deposit base and I
think the question about the proportion
of uninsured deposits in a bank uh you
know the higher that number you can say
the more vulnerable that bank is to a
run that can have serious implications
I think the second one is it's a very
old-fashioned issue
um
you know I've been throughout various
times in my career involved in
Prudential policy you know since the
late 1980s and I think this is going to
be the third time we're going around
interest rate risk in the banking book
um as an issue
um it's not in pillar one of Basel
um
because we've had several goes on this
issue
um it's in pillar two we in the UK we do
I mean there's two parts there's
obviously it's the accounting treatment
and as the capital treatment
accounting treatments differ you know
sorry for our banks they really are you
know more restricted in what they can
what they can hold in their hold to
maturity book as opposed to Fair valuing
which means they have to take the loss
of the losses they're taken through into
into p l into capital and we also
Implement we've fully implemented uh
interest rate risk in the banking book
so we're going to have to go around that
that issue again and you know in many
ways this is a very basic piece of
banking you don't need lots of new tech
to get to interest rate risk in the
banking book it's obviously fundamental
to what banks do so that's the second
it's the second one the third one is
resolution
um
so again I've been heavily involved in
resolution for a long time I did my
first resolution nearly 30 years ago
um
I think
I do push back on suggestions that the
the resolution framework we've got for
large Banks doesn't work I think it does
work actually the question is
do we use it
um
there is also and let me say because I I
you know I really don't criticize you
know on this because I you know I know
how difficult it is to do these things
so yeah the resolution framework is a
Playbook
um to use a sort of sporting analogy for
a moment and you know you can choose how
to use that Playbook and I think we must
give you know authorities you know the
credit to allow them to choose how to
use that Playbook uh and there is a
degree of art involved in that I mean
it's it's both a sort of Science and an
art in that sense
but I think there are you know there are
questions we're going to have to come
back to because if people feel they
can't use the resolution Playbook then
we've got to come back and ask really
fundamental question you know we've just
spent 10 years or more developing this
thing is it is it is it is it the right
thing I think I think it is actually but
I think you know another issue we've
then got is the question of four
smaller Banks
um where they're not issuing eligible
liabilities because they don't issue in
the market so they're not they're not
increasing their sort of you know their
wedge of loss bearing of liabilities
um how the deposits protection limits
work and this comes back to the
uninsured deposit points uh you know and
frankly I think you have to ask the hard
question I mean I'll you know are
uninsured deposits going to Bear losses
or not and if they're not and I'm not
presuming that but I mean this issue
comes up then you have to think very
hard well how do you resolve the bank
you mentioned the speed of deposit
withdrawals using current technology but
it was also the speed of Market
condition translating these problems uh
to Europe for a standard banking type
problem which you have during
normalization uh so Europe was equalized
to the situation in the U.S
any thoughts on how one could deal with
this kind of Market condition and avoid
it
I think
I mean there are some issues around
Market structure the the the CDs Market
is an extremely you know illiquid uh
markets and I think you know if you ask
many people I think you know in the sort
of in the business and said to them do
you think CDs really reflects a sort of
underlying sort of true sense of risk I
think they'd be quite skeptical
but I think there's another important
part to that's where we come in as
authorities and I think it's to do with
communication
I mean I I do think that yeah there are
times when we have to communicate our
view
on the system
and I'll say two things on this well
first thing is and I think we have to do
what I call fact-based reassurance I
think you could just come out and saying
don't worry it's all fine
um you know
it gets so there's a few journalists
laughing in the audience at this point
guys it doesn't go down terribly well
for good reasons I'm I'm sort of pretty
much in the same place
um so I think you have to do what I call
fact based you have to say look here's
the fact yeah here's the facts
here's the facts as we see them the key
sort of the key the key facts of the
system as we see it
and then the second point is and this is
the sort of you know where you've got
you've got to sort of turn the mirror
back on yourself if when you you say
well I'm gonna I'm gonna set these facts
out and you know if when you say well
here the facts are so what I'm going to
say and it's all right
if you get to that point and you say
well how's it looks so good does it um
you know then you know that you've
actually that you know just
communication isn't going to do it
you're going to have to do something
um you know that's a that's a that's a
really hard wake-up call at that point I
think so you're going to take some
action so I do think you know how we do
communication what we communicate
so fact-based communication and what
lessons and messages we take from those
facts is very important
uh while the stress has been in in the
banking sector a significant focus of
financial disability analysis and
international policy work has been on
non-bank financial intermediaries what
do you see as key language linkages
between Banks and non-banks in the
present conjuncture and what are the
common themes in your view between
recent banking sector stresses and
previous stress episodes in involving
non-bank Financial intermediaries
including the ldi crisis which you had
to manage well I think first of all one
of the things I would say having having
had some these experiences with banks in
the last few weeks
I think it's vital that we don't let our
agenda on non-banks become sidelined
um or or in sometimes relegated by
virtue of some issues coming up in the
banking world because the the gender
ones on non-banks is crucial you know
you know I chair the the supervision
regulation Committee of the of the
Global Financial stability board and our
our agenda is absolutely full with with
the non-back world
um we're going to find some time to do
some other things but
um and we've got to keep on doing that
so all the work on money market funds on
open-ended funds on crypto on stable
coins all this stuff has to has to go on
and I think what we've seen I mean first
of all I always say that the challenge
with the non-bank world is what I call
the breadth and the depth challenge it's
a huge landscape
uh it's got bigger post-financial crisis
I don't think that's particularly
surprising in terms of the relative
terms because one of the consequences of
of regulating the banks more
post-financial crisis has probably been
to sort of change the balance of
intermediation
it's actually also pretty heterogeneous
it's not a you know it's not the
non-bank world that is it's not a
homogeneous landscape
um it's that's the breadth part to it
the depth part to it is that what we've
learned is that you know some of these
problems can blow up in fairly small
pockets of that world but they have the
ability to spread in ways that you know
we didn't we didn't necessarily
initially predict
and one of the points I would pick out
there I think it's one of the features
of you know if we look at some of the
bigger non-bank experiences we've had in
the last three or four years so both the
dash for cash and
March 2020 the archangos incident
uh the ldi incident the nickel metal
Market incidents one of the things I
would pick out with all of those is that
you had institutions that were quite
large institutions that were the sort of
center of part of that each one of those
stories
who could only who really should have
only been able to understand their risk
if they could see the whole picture
they could see their part of the picture
and thought their part of the picture
looked reasonably normal
what they didn't see was that there was
another there was a whole big other part
of the picture out there so whether it
was because in the metal case you know
you you've got an on Exchange position
and you didn't see the OTC market out
there in arcados you'd got part of it
and you didn't seem to see that there
were a load of other people with other
quite big parts of it and that these
things were going to all come together
so that's another part of the story I
think that unless you can you know less
to risk manage those situations you have
to be able to see more than actually was
being seen at that time so I think
that's another part that we
you know we have to be able to address
final points I'd make about the non-bank
world and this is where you know the
question of how central banks come into
the picture because yeah I think one of
the things we've learned from this is
that we have to have a central bank
toolkit that can deal with these
problems and we used to say we're only
in the bank World
um I think you know we have to have
reserved tools as it were to deal with
extreme cases in the non-bank world
now I think you get a couple of things
thrown up by that one is is in central
banks is yeah we don't we don't regulate
many non-banks so we always sort of feel
well how we how do we feel having as
counterparties to our own operations
people we don't regulate that's the
first point
I think the second point is that of
course for many of the non many parts of
the non-back world it's an agency model
not a principle yeah the bank so it's a
principal model of business it's on
their balance sheet they've got assets
that they can pledge to us
um you know one of the things we found
in the ldi issue was that of course in
an agency World they didn't actually own
the assets so we one of the reasons we
had to do a market-wide intervention
was because trying to do a bilateral
intervention with the particular
counterparts didn't work because then
only assets it was an agency model
our efforts to address nbifi data gaps
and boosting their resilience
progressing and uh including the boe's
planned explanatory exploratory scenario
for nbfis well doing starting reverse I
mean one of the say one of the big
reasons for doing the exploratory survey
is because one of the things that I've
sort of pasteurized off on repeatedly is
what I call the breadth and the depth
issue is how do we survey such a big
landscape
at the depth that we need to survey it
to to spot you know spot where these
things are you know cropping up and
we've got to come up and this is
globally it's not domestic because you
can't see the parts separately we've got
to come up with ways of doing that
effectively
um I what I would say on how are the
really good question on how is it
progressing in terms of the work
well some of it's some of it's further
up the pipeline than other parts of it
um the piece that has probably made most
progress is the work further work on
money market funds but I will make this
money yeah the FSB
can do its work on global standards but
it has to be implemented
and at the moment you know the
implementation record is is too patchy
at the moment
so we've got to have consistent
implementation on this uh in this
landscape
I think we have five minutes for
questions from the audience uh are there
any
yes please
I think we need a microphone here
maybe you start us off and then uh you
know we'll come to you though yeah
thanks very much can you hear me
thank you very much for the uh very nice
presentation
I guess one world with the word that we
didn't address is the uncertainty
and uh so initial question is how does
this first best option of clear
separation between the aims objectives
and the tools between price and
financial stability changes in uncertain
times right now the big question is the
financial dominance issue because
everybody's questioning whether the
monetary policy will be
ready to um act and as you said not to
aim of
because of the financial stability
reason so the question is do you think
monetary policy should act more
forcefully during uncertainty or
actually be more careful during the
uncertain times Well I I think you have
to distinguish excuse me um
uncertainty about the general economic
conditions that we face and therefore
about the sort of the range of potential
inflation outcomes
and uncertainty about the financial
system I think again I would I would I
would keep those two sort of distinct in
terms of the tools we use because I
think that's appropriate so in a way we
should address uncertainty into the
world in those worlds just the same as
we address the sort of a sense the sort
of center of the distribution oh
um
So within in the monetary policy world
you know we had yeah we we spent a lot
of time on uncertainty we published fan
charts which attempt to convey some of
the sense of uncertainty
and at the moment I would you know just
say in terms of both the distribution of
uncertainty and the distribution of risk
for instance we've got the biggest
upside we've got the biggest skew on
inflation I think either way
in the history of the NPC which is now
over 25 years so the the upside risk on
inflation further out on the uh on the
fan chart is the largest and that of
course then you know that's that's the
forecast we then have to use that as
that's just one tool in our
decision-making process but how we each
of us thinks about conveying that
turning that uncertainty into a policy
decision is obviously something we go
through on the financial stability side
I think it's it's crucial I mean it's a
very good point you make you know if we
are highly uncertain about our
assessment of the system then we've got
to take measures that you know take that
into account within the world of
financial stability I mean it would
certainly in the in the Prudential World
macron micro if we were facing that
situation I would want to be more
aggressive in terms of the financial
stability measures that we take to
reflect that
sorry I hope I'm not being drowned out
by the
noise I think we can hear you yeah
I have one question uh during covet
there was a lot of forbearance by
countries
so the credit rates the quality of uh of
loans we really don't know the quality
of those loans because some of them were
actually restructured
and now that interest rates are going up
they're not just affecting the banks
they're affecting the banks through
duration risk but they also affect the
corporates so we are going to have a
double whammy in terms of credit risk as
well as a duration risk so if we have
that combination and we have the
financial stability can we really still
separate uh you know to the extent that
monetary policy transmits through
financial institutions
who will not be in a position where we
have to pay attention to financial
stability to actually influence monetary
policy
well I think you make a very good point
that of course the combination or
potentially the combination of The
Lending policies during covert and the
increase in interest rates could
interact
in quite a difficult way potentially
now I think first of all I mean you know
it is we spend a lot of time focused on
credit quality both in household
borrowing and and corporate borrowing
the second I can only speak for our own
situation now
um is that we have changed the uh
accounting provisioning standards in in
the last few years so that we have now
reintroduced a much larger element of
expected loss provisioning you want me
to see hopefully this uh
that's all we've introduced a much
larger well we've it's reintroduced
expected loss provisioning in a much
more organized and sort of systematic
way and so the banks are now one of the
tools that they have and we have is uh
what you know what level of expected
loss provisioning they should hold as
part of their overall buffers uh against
loan loss provisions and Loan losses
sorry and I think that's an important
element to it so you know it it makes me
more reassured that they've got those
Provisions in place uh ahead of losses
crystallizing because as you probably
know we used to be in a situation where
provisioning had to sort of wait until
loss is crystallized which in a sense is
too late
and last question over there hi uh
tonight London School of Economics um
you spoke you said that you don't see
evidence that we're in the makings of
another 2008 that this time is different
and we have more tools in the Armory you
also spoke about fact-based reassurance
which facts if they were true would make
you change your mind and be more worried
oh well I mean I think first of all I
mean looking at obviously I mean
obviously looking at the the sort of the
the building blocks I mean first of all
capital ratios
um and how we expect those Capital
ratios to evolve under stress I'll come
back to stress testing in a moment and
then the same thing for obviously
liquidity ratios both the the liquidity
coverage ratio and the net stable
funding ratio they are both important
elements I mean it yeah one thing I'd
emphasize because you sometimes hear
different commentary on that on these
things that you know the post-financial
crisis liquidity policy has two elements
to it and and you could you know we
shouldn't assume that one is sort of
better than the other or one replaces
the other we need both of them because
the LCR is a more short term in a sense
measure in the nsfr is a more medium
term come back to stress for a moment I
think you know it underlines the
importance of stress testing
but let me say two things on that first
of all you know it's important to use
you know several scenarios
you know in stress tests I mean we've
always taken the vi voice technology
we've always taken a few there are
basically two scenarios
in in bank stress tests for rates
one is a what I call a rates up in a
recession scenario so this is where
you're doing yeah the thing that you
don't want to do you're having to put
rates up heavily in us or not in a
recession and that's true and that's a
that's a stress test on banks the second
one is a is a low for very long scenario
where you'll sort of pinned at the sort
of you know the lower Bound for for sort
of the duration as it were and and both
of those are important uh to do
um we're currently running a stress test
at the moment which is a you know is a
rates up scenario
um with with say with a pretty negative
stressed scenario in terms of the
economic prospects and you have to do
both of those two things
um I would
however say because I you know this does
get said sometimes and applies both to
the bank and the non-back world of
course you have to pick your stress
points I mean I think it's important so
you know it's like forecasting yeah we
we can pick we can pick stress tests
based on sort of forecasts and obviously
they're forecast for the tail of the
distribution
yeah black swans can happen beyond that
and you have to have other tools whether
they're resolution tools or intervention
tools are the sort we used in the ldi
market so to take care of those things
that you know you don't have in what I
call this approach in in history where
you sort of take history and add
something on but you're not claiming
that you can foresee every possible
event that could happen in the future
because none of us can frankly
mm-hmm good
thank you very much and Andrew for all
your insights uh thank you for all of
you attending and the big uh a round of
applause please